هذا الممر يمكنه منافسة قناة
السويس بوصفه طريقا رئيسيا
قال لبوريل عليك ان تقرأ ما
كتبتموه بعناية قبل ان تحذرنا.
لاردوغان في صراعه الانتخابي
صعيد اخر قال منسق السياسة
المصري وذلك بتوقيع طهران وموسكو
اتفاقا لتمويل وانشاء خط للسكك
فقرار مجلس الاتحاد الاوروبي
يقول ان النفط الروسي الذي خضع
الاراضي المصرية تجاه دول اوروبا
وكالعادة لكل فعل ردة فعل. الرد
السيسي مع اسرائيل بشأن مد
انابيب النفط الاسرائيلي من
ومن بين ركام الحرب يظهر الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوجان بخبر
الاتحاد الاوروبي اتخاذ اجراءات
صارمة ضد الهند التي تعيد بيع
وقع الاتحاد الاوروبي واسرائيل
ومصر مذكرة تفاهم اليوم تهدف الى
الروسي لا يتأخر. حيث وجهت روسيا
وايران ضربة موجعة لقناة السويس
الحديدية في ايران ليكون جزءا من
خطة اقتصادية بحتة الهدف منها
اقامة ممر نقل دولي يربط بين
الشمال والجنوب. وتقول روسيا ان
للتجارة العالمية بحسب رويترز.
ومن اجل المصداقية اليكم المصدر.
فورا وعلى لسان وزير الخارجية
الهندي سوبرمانيوم جيشنكار الذي
روسيا. هل هو تشجيع امريكي
لتايوان لتدخل حربا ضد الصين؟
الخارجية بالاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيف بوريل انه يتعين على
السريع من انها لن تتردد في
التصدي لاي تصرفات من قبل رجال
النفط الروسي الى اوروبا كوقود
بعد تكريره ليأتي الرد الهندي
هناك ارتباطا تقنيا كبيرا بين
تطوير الصواريخ الباليستية
الامريكيين حيث طالبت امريكا
روسيا بالافراج عن الامريكيين
قالت وزيرة خارجية المانيا
انالينا بيربوك ان المانيا ترغب
في نزاع هم ليسوا طرفا فيه على
حد وصفها. وحذرت قوات الدعم
سيجعل العالم مطمئنا ولو قليلا
على غذائه حيث اكد اردوجان توصل
التوسع في الطاقة المتجددة. بعد
ان بدأت ملامح المواجهة المباشرة
لمعالجة عميقة في بلد ثالث لم
يعد يعتبر روسيا. وبعد ان وقع
ان تصد دولة عظيمة كالصين.
والدليل ما تفعله اوكرانيا امام
بين الروس والامريكان في
اوكرانيا. برأيكم هل يتم تصعيد
المعارك على الارض اعلنت كييف
استعادة نحو عشرين كيلو مترا
جميع الاطراف المعنية الى اتفاق
لتمديد تصدير الحبوب ضمن صفقة
تفقد الزعيم الكوري كيم جونغ اون
اول قمر اصطناعي للتجسس العسكري
واضافت بيربوك ان المانيا تسعى
للاتفاق على هدف عالمي ملزم بشأن
العابرة للقارات وقدرات الاطلاق
الفضائي لدى كوريا الشمالية.
الرياضة العسكرية في الخرطوم بعد
معارك مع قوات الجيش السوداني.
تعزيز صادرات غاز شرقي البحر
المتوسط الى اوروبا. هذا الطريق
في تحقيق الاستقرار في امدادات
الطاقة من خلال التعاون مع
في بلاده واعطى الضوء الاخضر
لاطلاقه. ويرى محللون غربيون ان
مشاهدينا يختصر الوقت من اربعين
يوما في البحر الى عشرين يوما
كما دعت قوات الدعم السريع رجال
الشرطة السودانية الى عدم الدخول
الشرطة او اي جهة اخرى ضد
عناصرها حسب بيان صادر عنها.
ويتفادى رسوم قناة السويس.
الاحداث والتطورات. نشرت قوات
الحبوب مدة شهرين اضافيين. فهل
يحمل هذا الخبر فألا حسنا
الدعم السريع مشاهد من سيطرتها
على موقع قوات الدفاع الجوي وفرع
تصدي جيش صغير لجيش اكبر. اي انه
يقول يمكن لدولة صغيرة كتايوان
المحتجزين. وذلك بحسب وزير
الخارجية الروسي سيرجي لافروف.
فماذا عن الملف الاوكراني ليجيب
وزير الدفاع الامريكي لوي دوستون
ان حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا تقدم
درسا قيما لتايوان بشأن امكانية
للاستسلام وفق وكالة. مهلا مهلا
مهلا فهنا واشنطن تفاوض موسكو
لكن الامريكان لا يفاوضون الا
على ملف واحد. وهو ملف المحتجزين
مربعا في شمال بمدينة باخموت.
بينما اطلقت القوات الروسية
خلال اعلان استقالته وذلك بحسب
مجلة سبستاك. وبالعودة الى
صواريخ غير منفجرة على مواقع
اوكرانية محملة بمنشورات تدعوهم
البولندي اندري دودا ان وارسو
سلمت معظم طائراتها المقاتلة من
الاسلحة الغربية ها هي فرنسا
تعطي المزيد وذلك بتدريب
طراز تسعة وعشرين الى اوكرانيا
كما طلبت منهم كييف فان ذهبت تلك
الامريكي المرموق سيمور هيرش ان
مجموعة من الدول تقودها بولندا
الطيارين الاوكران وتزويدهم
بعتاد عسكري ضخم فهل يجدي ذلك
نفعا. وهنا تظهر الخسارة
الحقيقية. حيث كشف الصحفي
تدعو سرا الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي
لانهاء الصراع حتى لو كان ذلك من
الحرب هل التهم الروس كل تلك
الاسلحة؟ ومع خسارة كل هذه
مضاد بسبب ارهاق وحالة الانهاك
في صفوف قواته بعد خمسة عشر شهرا
من الصراع وفق صحيفة ولكن ماذا
عن الدعم الغربي الضخم منذ بداية
الطائرات اذا ليزيد من الشعار
البيت. بقوله انه يخشى شن هجوم
وسيحدد ذلك ما اذا كان يجب سحب
المنظومة كليا او اصلاحها على
ان الغرب سيتعامل مع مصادر
المعلومات الروسية بجدية اكبر
فكيف سيقاوم الاوكران صواريخ
بوتين ان تم سحب هذه وبعد
الفور من قبل القوات الاوكرانية.
ها للعجب هذه المنظومة ما لبثت
تكون منظومة الدفاع الجوي من
طراز باتريوت قد تعرضت لاضرار
كافية لتحقيق النصر بحسب صحيفة
الجارديان حيث اعلن الرئيس
الاعتراف الامريكي باصابة
باتريوت ذكرت صحيفة البريطانية
الاوكرانية. ولتخفيف هذه الخسائر
الاوكرانية كان الرئيس الاوكراني
فالمعلومات الروسية التي تعلنها
موسكو هي من كانت الادق بحسب
بشكل تام وان الولايات المتحدة
لا تزال تقيم الى اي درجة تضررت
الخبر اليقين باعتراف امريكي حين
رجح مسؤول امريكي لشبكة سي ان ان
نتيجة قصف صاروخي روسي على كييف
ومحيطها موضحا ان منظومة لم تدمر
تدمير قواتها لمنظومة في
اوكرانيا وكييب تنفي ذلك. ليأتي
في اوكرانيا لمساعدتها في الحرب
حتى اقتربت واشنطن من سحبها.
الصحيفة البريطانية. ومن مواجهة
موسكو وواشنطن نعود الى الحرب
زينونسكي قد قام بجولة في الدول
ليعود محملا بالهدايا لكنها غير
كانت قد اندلعت بين منظومة
باتريوت الامريكية صواريخ
تحرشات لم ترق لاشعال فتيل
المواجهة مناوشات هنا وهناك.
مواجهة مباشرة بين واشنطن
وموسكو. نعم يا سادة المواجهة
الروسية الاسرع من الصوت وكل
يغني على ليلاه. موسكو تعلن
وبعد عام وعدة اشهر منذ بدء حرب
اوكرانيا. ها نحن نشهد اول
والمانيا تتودد لقطر. المواجهة
المباشرة تبدأ. حرب عن بعد.
الشمالية يكشف الستار عن سلاحه
الخفي في تطوير الصواريخ
للمصريين بشأن اتفاقية النفط
الاسرائيلي. وزعيم كوريا
تهاجم الهند وتتهمها بالخيانة.
وقبل خوضه جولة اعادة الانتخابات
السريع السوداني تسيطر على قيادة
الدفاع الجوي ورد روسي موجع
هي الاكثر ثقة. ولهذا السبب يخشى
من الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد.
اردوجان يقدم هدية روسية
اوكرانية لجميع الدول. والدعم
تنفجر. وبولندا تطالب من الرئيس
الاوكراني استقالته واوروبا
وبطريقة غريبة موسكو لاول مرة
تطلق صواريخ على اوكرانيا ولا
المواجهة لتصبح حربا رسمية بين
الطرفين.